the first travel ban led to massive
protests and was eventually shut down by
a federal court obviously yeah obviously
obviously President Trump and his team
are hoping for a better reception
this time around in fact the White House
even released this new ad check it out
when the White House issued its travel
ban for Muslim countries everyone agreed
the ban was a disaster and travel from
Muslim countries resumed but not so fast
now we've got a new improved travel ban
it's got everything nervous white people
loved about the travel ban with some
incredible new features a more
lighthearted typeface printed on
soothing yellow paper double reinforced
staples and a recipe for Jeff Sessions
homemade squirrel pie plus by popular
demand we've removed Iraq from the ban
and we replaced it with Samoa justice
sorry Samoans so let's hear it for the
new slightly less unconstitutional
travel ban
and you wanna fire but you can't come in
you're gonna love the way we hate happy
[Applause]
you